Hello everyone and welcome to Citizen by CNN
I'm Jessica Schneider justice correspondent
here at CNN. Thank you all so much for joining
us. We have an all star panel today and we
were excited. I'll introduce them in just
a minute. But we also want to hear from all
of you watching throughout this conversation
and the way you can do that is by going to
the lower box to the right of the player.
That's what we'll be able to submit some questions.
We already have some questions in the queue,
so looking forward to all of the questions
that any of you may ask. So of course we are
just less than two weeks away from the midterm
elections and just about two years away from
the presidential election. So we want to talk
about voting rights and in particular voting
rights in the Supreme Court and all of the
cases that the Supreme Court has already decided
on and the cases they have heard and will
hear this term dealing with voting rights.
So we'll be talking with a panel of experts
and I want to introduce them first we have
senior Supreme Court analyst, joan Biskupic.
Then we have Bradley heard he is um at the
Southern poverty poverty Law Center and he's
the deputy legal director there for the voting
rights practice group, a crucial group. And
then we have Elie Honig, he's our senior legal
analyst here at CNN, he's also a former state
and federal prosecutor. So thanks to all of
them for joining. You know, we are seeing
a lot of crucial action at the Supreme Court
when it comes to voting rights. So before
we jump into the nitty gritty here, I kind
of want to encapsulate what's happened at
the Supreme Court over the last decade. And
a lot of the decisions that the Supreme Court
has issued over that decade, critics have
said have have really come as a detriment
to minority voters. It was back in 2013 when
the very important Shelby County decision
was issued by the Supreme Court and that really
gutted section five of the voting rights Act.
And that meant that states that in the past
that had to get federal clearance for any
new voting provisions, they no longer had
to get that clearance and they could enact
these voting provisions without getting the
okay the green light first. And then groups
would have to challenge them after under Section
two, Section two is now really what's being
lit And the lower courts and has now come
up to the Supreme Court, it was just last
year, in 2021, the Supreme Court actually
upheld to Arizona voting regulations, that
people critics viewed as detrimental to minority
groups. The Supreme Court upheld that and
then they also suggested in their decision
that the state's interest um like preventing
voter fraud could really outweigh concern
concerns from people bringing up these concerns
about how it might impact minority groups.
So that was Barnevik in 2021 this term. They
just heard arguments about Alabama and redistricting
and how section two factors in in particular,
the majority minority groups, I should say,
who are disputing these districting lines
say that they should have more than one of
the seven Uh majority minority districts.
And they say that's because black voters make
up 27% of the state of Alabama and they should
be entitled to having more than just one district
where they are a majority. And then coming
up on December seven, the Supreme Court will
hear a case that we're also going to talk
about about the independent state legislature
theory that really says that state legislatures
have ultimate authority over state courts
when it comes to determining voting regulations,
including redistricting. So that's gonna be
a big one as well. That is a big talker here.
So hopefully that's a good recap for you.
Don't worry, if you didn't catch it all, we'll
touch on it throughout this conversation.
So Bradley heard I really want to start with
you because you oversee the voting rights
practice group at the Southern Poverty Law
Center. Can you tell us, you know, how important
these cases are, what's its Supreme Court
this term especially and how it will impact
um voters, minority voters. I specifically
have a question from David in michigan, he
says, how can black voters and other historically
excluded groups prepare for potential voter
suppression tactics. So, can you weigh in
on that and how important this term is at
the Supreme court? Well, first, thank you
for having me Jessica. It's a pleasure to
join you all and to join the rest of the panel.
Um I think you laid it out perfectly in your
intro. Um what's at stake is um is the ability
of marginalized groups, communities of color,
language minorities to protect voting rights
um to to come to the courts to seek relief
and protect voting rights. Voting rights is
on the Supreme Court docket and it's on the
ballot. Uh So I I would say that and as to
the question, um it's a very prescient question.
Um I think that the best tool that uh black
voters or other communities of color could
handle uh is to is to be prepared and be on
watch because um we know that there are efforts
out there to suppress the vote to intimidate
we saw recently in the news, those uh people
standing uh in masks and with long guns around
absentee drop boxes. Um You know, there's
all sorts of, there's all sorts of intimidation
in in the vicinity of polling sites on Election
day misinformation. I would say a few things
one make sure before you go to the polls plan
your vote, make sure that you are at the right
polling place that you know where you're supposed
to be double check your registration status.
Um And once you're there, stand in line if
you're there at the time that polling places
close, stand in line, you have the right to
vote. If you show up at your polling place
and they and you know that you're in the correct
polling place based on your address, but they
don't have you on the rolls. Ask for a provisional
ballot. That's your right under federal law.
Um you have to you have to know in your heart
that you have the right to vote and to be
prepared to exercise that right in the face
of clear voter suppression, important points.
And I won't I'll get back to you Bradley on
a few more tips that you might have. But ellie,
you know, I want to give people who are watching
an understanding, a greater understanding
of the voting rights act. You know, we saw
section five really gutted and that was this
preclearance provision. So now, the only real
remedy for people who believe that they might
be disenfranchised is to go via section two
of the voting rights act. Can you break down
that section a bit, tell us what entails and
how people can get some relief using section
two? Sure jess. So, under the voting rights
Act, there were really two tools that people
could have if they wanted to challenge the
way that States gerrymandering, the way the
States set their voting districts are voting
procedures, Section five and section two,
Section five, as you said, is essentially
gone. Now it was wiped out in 2013 in the
Shelby County versus holder that used to require
states, certain states to go to doJ and get
preclearance for any new voting provisions.
Any new voting arrangements. The drawing of
voting lines on the theory that you have these
certain areas of the country where there's
a demonstrated established history of discriminatory
practices in voting and there was a memorable
sort of back and forth in that opinion where
the majority said essentially we don't need
it anymore. We've grown, we've progressed,
we don't have these same problems anymore.
And Justice Ginsburg and I think a memorable
descent said that's like arguing that you
don't need an umbrella anymore in a rainstorm
because you're not getting wet. I mean, you
know, I'm not getting the exact quote right,
but the whole point of why you're not getting
wet is because of the umbrella. Nonetheless,
that is the law. Now, that is the ruling of
the Supreme Court and so there is no more.
Section five, which leaves people with only
Section two of the voting rights Act, which
essentially makes it illegal to discriminate
in voting regulations, voting laws on the
basis of race, sex, gender, national origin
etcetera. But the question that's before the
court, I think now in the Merrill case is
essentially, do we look, does the plaintiff
does the person challenging the state's voting
requirements have to show discriminatory intent
or is it enough to show a discriminatory impact.
And of course it's much harder to show discriminatory
intent because rarely are people, officials,
policymakers going to say, hey, let's draw
it this way so we can discriminate against
so and so it's really hard to prove that instead,
what traditionally has been done, as you say,
regardless of whatever the intent might have
been, which we're not really able to demonstrate,
here's the result you have X percent of the
state is let's is black, let's say to use
the most common example, but only half of
that will result in seats. You know, that
will go to potentially to black winner. So
in other words, the idea is you're setting
up a certain population so that they will
have vastly disproportionate under representation
in the election. So the question for the Supreme
Court is what has to be shown here. And look,
I I mean, I guess we'll get a little bit into
what do we first see? But this is a 6 to 3
Supreme Court, even if robert's remains a
sort of centrist middle vote, you still have
five pretty dyed in the wool conservatives
and I think the more likely outcome is we
do continue to see Section two eroded, which
I think is a real conservative people like
Bradley people who are on that side of the
voting rights dispute. Yeah. And you know
what Ellie that exact quote, because I wrote
it down Justice Ginsburg said the decision
kind of gutting section five because oh, we
don't need it anymore. We don't need this
preclearance anymore. Was like throwing away
your umbrella in a rainstorm because you're
not getting wet, you were very close on that.
So joan, let's bring you into this conversation
here because you very closely followed the
Supreme Court. You've been doing it I think
for several decades now and you do it wonderfully.
Um talk to us a little bit about what you're
seeing set up this term. Um you know, last
term we saw that brnovich decision where they
sort of whittled away a little bit of section
two when it came to those two Arizona voting
provisions. So what do you see? I mean I have
one question here from Adam in new york and
he says, is the Supreme Court likely to eliminate
the voting rights act this term from the Meryl
cases. And if they do, what's the future of
voting rights in this country? And I obviously
I don't think they won't completely eliminate
the voting rights act, but they seem to be
continually whittling down Section two. What's
your takeaway so far? That's right. Thanks
to us and so glad to be here with my fellow
panelists uh I was in the courtroom for that
case from Alabama that Ellie just referred
to. That's testing how easy it will be for
anyone to bring a discrimination case under
Section two of the voting rights act. They're
not going to get rid of it. They're just going
to make it harder and harder, I believe based
on the oral arguments and based on the pattern
of this court to bring claims, for example,
in the Alabama case, the issue is whether
the state had to draw to majority black districts
because as you said yes, the 27% black population,
but only one district of the seven. And the
lower court had said under traditional districting
principles, you should be able to draw too.
And so I think where the court is headed is
to make it harder to challenge state legislative
practices that uh dilute in the end dilute
black votes, but they're not going to get
rid of section two the way they did section
five and just step back for a minute and tell
you about sort of the tone of this current
Supreme Court on voting rights. You know,
I've been watching it for a long time and
obviously Shelby County was a turning point
and you saw five justice majority uh really
flex its muscle on voting rights. Uh you know,
led by john roberts, this is not an area of
the law where john roberts is taking a middle
ground, john roberts is essentially leading
the charge. But during those arguments in
the Alabama case, the dynamic was so different
where the conservatives hardly said anything
because they are so clearly winning justice
Neil gorsuch did not ask a single question.
Justice Clarence thomas said very little,
even the chief said little, The whole conversation
was driven by the three liberal justices,
all women, one white, one black one hispanic,
all trying to change the narrative on race.
Instead of saying as the current majority
believes that things are okay now or that
the country needs to move more toward a race
concept of race neutrality. Justice New Justice
Jackson, for example, try to bring the story
back to the idea that uh federal law and also
the constitution's equal protection guarantee
were all based on the idea that you have to
consider race to get beyond discrimination
to bring about equality. So I think that we're
going to see in this area of the law more
inter incremental chipping away at the voting
rights act, which it's so interesting that
yet we have another case from Alabama because
obviously the 1965 voting rights act was passed
only after the the bloody sunday incident
in 1965. In Selma Alabama on the uh, Edmund
Pettus Bridge, that you know, spurred the
nation to believe that we need the voting
rights act. And in those oral arguments that
both Bradley and Ellie have referred to earlier
this month, Justice Kagan said This, this
is a gem of our country, the voting rights
act. And you keep eviscerating it when you,
when you ruled in Shelby County, you said,
Okay, you don't really need section five because
you have section two dealing with discrimination
after the fact. And then in 2021 case of Brenda
from Arizona, you curtailed it a bit. And
I said, oh no, don't worry. You know, it's
still available for vote delusion claims.
And she said, where are we now? What are we
actually left with? Yeah. And I want to get
more into chief justice john roberts in just
a minute joan. But Bradley, let me ask you
in this case that's going to be decided later
this term out of Alabama. The Alabama solicitor
general actually said that race should not
be considered when it comes to redistricting.
He said that would be a violation of the constitution.
Who knows if the justices will buy that argument?
Um The challengers definitely pushed against
that. But what is your take on this argument?
That race isn't even something that should
be looked at when it comes to redistricting?
Obviously that might help. Um, Alabama's case
in this instance. It's it's preposterous jess.
I mean to just uh, put a fine point on it.
And uh, let's let's go back to the point joan
was just making, I mean, all of these landmark
voting rights cases, she mentioned that the
um, the voting rights act itself came after
bloody sunday in Selma Alabama. The uh, the
Shelby case in 2013 that eliminated essentially
eliminated section five of the voting rights
act came out of Shelby County in Alabama.
Now we are back before the Supreme Court with
yet another case this time of redistricting
case coming out of the state of Alabama and
for Alabama to walk into the Supreme Court
and to say with a straight face that the way
to address uh discrimination, discrimination
and voting is to take a race blind approach
to Section two of the voting rights act is
just devoid of common sense. Uh it's devoid
of any sort of historical context. Um and
I think this is the point that Justice Jackson
just made so beautifully and as a, you know,
speaking as a black lawyer and as a as a person
who is now leading a team of voting rights
uh warriors at the Southern poverty Law center.
I mean, I was so proud of Justice Jackson
when she just took a moment to pause and say,
listen, this act has a historical context,
the constitution has a historical context,
it is not race neutral. Um The 13th, 14th
and 15th amendments were born out of the Civil
war um and they were born out of an effort
to help newly emancipated african americans
two, a avoid slavery, be become full citizens
in this country and see exercise the right
to vote. So to conceive of of to conceive
of Section two of the voting rights act in
any sort of race blind way. It's just a preposterous
argument from the state of Alabama. And you
know what, we're getting a lot of questions
in our producer jess Moskowitz is texting
me as we go along. So, I guess based on the
questions I'm getting in, guys, I kind of
want to shift the focus because I was going
to drill more into, you know, the voting rights
Act, but it seems like people on the whole
and Ellie you might be able to talk about
this off the bat. People are concerned in
general about the court's legitimacy and this
is something that we've seen as a hot topic
after the overturning of roe v wade throughout
the summer. In fact, Justice Alito just talked
about it last night in his talk kind of pushing
against the comments from Justices Sotomayor
and Kagan about concerns about the legitimacy
of the court. You know, Alito last night saying
you can question the decisions of the court,
but not the court itself. So, Ellie, I want
to start with you talking about how this,
this perception of potential illegitimacy
of the court, um how it reverberates how people
are viewing the court and then maybe especially
if they start rolling back parts of the voting
rights act to, you know, affect how minority
voters are treated, how this might further
impact the courts as as it's perceived. So,
I think the Supreme Court has a is going through
a real crisis in public confidence right now.
Certainly unlike anything I've seen, I'd be
interested to hear jones view on the broader
historical context here, but nothing I've
seen in my lifetime can compare to this to
the lack of public faith in the court itself,
I don't like to question the legitimacy. I
I push back a little bit when people say the
courts not legitimate. I mean all these justices
through the politics were properly nominated
and confirmed and I don't think we should
be saying any of these justices is illegitimate,
but I think it's absolutely fair game to say
the court has lost the presumption of being
non political and a political. And that really
goes both ways. I'm not necessarily saying
it's, it's an equal equation, but both sides
have become so utterly predictable in where
they will come out and it's always based on
outcome. It's always based on the fact that
you can so reliably predict right now. How
will the case come out by arguing? Well, what's
the liberal outcome? You know, the three liberal
justices will land there or would have last
time with brian and replaced by Jackson and
what's the conservative outcome? And at least
the five and maybe all six will land there.
And to me, it undermines the whole notion
that these are umpires calling balls and strikes,
because umpires sometimes called balls sometimes
called strikes. It's more like the team in
the field calls everything a strike, the team
at bat calls everything a ball. And it's eminently
predictable. Um, I am personally, really,
really sick and tired of being lectured by
these justices, they live in this cloistered
world where they're all powerful and they
serve for life and if they wag a finger their
clerks go running and everything they say
goes, but I've had enough with Samuel alito
and Clarence thomas and frankly Stephen Bryer
lecturing us outside of the court about how
non political they are and how how dare we
have any questions to the contrary Because
the behavior, the actual decisions rendered
by the court over the last several years have
completely undermined this notion that they're
non political, that they're a political. And
by the way, this new trend towards the Supreme
Court justices becoming celebrities and writing
memoirs. I think I did account last summer
and five of the nine, you can't get across
ideological majority on much, but five of
nine across across the ideological spectrum
have written books have done. Speaking tours
have gotten multimillion dollar advances.
I think Amy coney Barrett got a multi million
dollar advance reportedly on her book within
months of taking the bench. So my faith in
the Supreme Court's impartiality and a political
nest is very, very low right now. And I think
the way to fix that is to actually show it
in the rulings and not to just constantly
lecture us about it. Well, I want to get joan
weighing in on that because obviously she
follows these justices very closely and joan
um it seems as if these justices well in particular,
Justice Alito Sotomayor Kagan in recent weeks
slash months have been very outspoken in their
speeches. Justice Alito even issued a statement
to the The Wall Street Journal, which was
fairly unprecedented. So I want to get your
take on that and then I'll just throw in a
question that you can kind of uh wind into
your answer, Janet Shapiro from New Jersey
says, since the Supreme Court has become so
politicized, that's her view, how can we trust
that they will adjudicate correctly if a state
tries to implement voting regulations that
negatively impact minority groups so you can
take both of those and answer it how you will.
Sure. And that question, Jessica is exactly
why the Supreme Court should be concerned
about public confidence in it as an institution
because it has, it doesn't have as the cliche
goes, the power of the purse or an army. It
only has its integrity and its stature. And
if, if the public starts to not have faith
in its rulings, why will it abide by it back
in 2000 with Bush v. Gore when the Supreme
Court essentially decided the election by
a single vote? People abided by it in 2020
between trump and biden. I wondered if, you
know, if a conservative dominated court would
issue a ruling that people would have similar
confidence and it's only become more deeply
partisan and just to address kind of what
makes this different, You know, certainly
at the beginning of the 19 hundreds when FDR
was attacking the court as nine old men and
it was all this talk about potential court
expansion court packing the court was controversial
during Earl Warren's uh stewardship as chief
justice. There were impeach Earl Warren signs
throughout the south for some of the rulings,
but those two episodes did not break it down
along both ideological and political lines
right now, what we have is a court where all
the republican appointees are voting essentially
in lock stop step with the chief, you know,
varying a little bit and the democrat appointees
are voting in a different way. And I just
want to say what has pushed so many people
over the edge has been the reversal of roe
v wade where president trump vowed to put
on justices who would reverse roe. All three
of those justices voted to reverse roe in
a case in which the actual question the justices
were being asked to decide and the justices
agreed to take the case on was not reversal
of roe. So that has played into the question
of is the, is the court fair, is the court
on the level. And so I do think those are,
are very legitimate questions. And then just
segue quickly Jessica to your question about
what the justices themselves are doing. Now,
first of all, I think you're going to see
more from justice Kagan and more from justice
Sotomayor and we'll have to wait and see what
justice Jackson does outside of the court
building calling attention to issues of legitimacy
as they see it? They have no nothing else
right now. You know, they are down to three
votes, which is again, you know, talk about
in our lifetime, we've mostly had a 54 chord.
The sixth three court is a whole, another
animal and very difficult for them to be struggling
with. So they are taking their case to the
public. And then when you have mainly Sam
alito right now, speaking about how you shouldn't
question the court, both he and Chief Justice
roberts for the little bit that he weighed
in Jessica made it sound like people were
questioning the court because of the decisions,
because of the bottom line rulings. But that's
not quite right. Because what people are seeing
is the reversal of decades old precedent.
It's not just that they don't like the bottom
line rulings, it's that they don't trust the
process. And I think that's, that's what should
give everybody concern, especially as we go
into two more election cycles. And let's just
say for 2020 for if there is an issue and
the Supreme Court is called upon to decide
a presidential election. How much faith will
the Supreme Court will the public have in
this supreme court. That's a great point.
And Bradley, I want to bring you in here,
you know, in your position at the southern
poverty law center? What are you hearing from
your attorneys, from people who might come
to your group? Um what are their concerns
about, you know, the politic politicization
of the Supreme Court. Are those big concerns
when it comes to the fact that they will be
considering two crucial voting rights cases
this term? Well, it's a huge concern. Um you
know, people uh people rely on the fairness
of the courts and right now people don't believe
that they're getting a fair shake out of these
courts. Um You have seen an effort by the
Supreme Court this just this term uh to to
sort of interpret the Purcell doctrine, which
is this uh you know, theory that the court
has recently adopted that says that it's it's
probably not a good idea for courts to get
involved uh in in cases to close in voting
cases too close to an election. Well, you
know, some of the some of the most serious
charges related to elections happened near
the election. But interpreting that in a way
that allows the state of Alabama for instance,
you had a unanimous three judge court um with
two trump appointees um saying that Alabama's
congressional map was discriminatory on the
basis of race and they ordered Alabama to
stop it. And then, you know, what does the
Supreme Court do as well, it's too close to
an election. So we're gonna let the bad map
stay there. Same thing happened in Louisiana
with their map. Uh the Lower Court says the
map is discriminatory, got to do something
else. Supreme Court steps in. No, you you're
you're gonna have to use the bad map and the
same thing in north Carolina. So it's a legitimate
question that that people come to us and say,
well is it gonna matter? Are we going to get
a fair shake and even if the lower courts
stand with us, you know, is it just gonna
get overturned? Uh you know, by a higher court?
That's it's a very serious and that is such
an important and actually interesting point
Bradley that I want to jump off maybe to ask
joan about because you're right, these two
lower courts um out of out of Alabama. Um
or sorry that the lower court out of Alabama
did say that the New day district maps violated
the voting rights act. So joan, why does in
that case, when it seems pretty clear cut,
why does the Supreme Court jump in and can
it be read any other way than maybe they want
to kind of rework the interpretation of section
two of the voting rights act? Well, that's
a good question and a couple of things on
that. Uh these voting rights cases. Uh Many
of them as in in the Alabama won the Supreme
Court does have jurisdiction. It's kind of
a mandatory jurisdiction where they will hear
it. Um But they have signaled enough a kind
of aggressive approach to these based on some
of their their other actions that led up to
this, for example, uh reversing the lower
court for for the current election cycle before
they even heard the merits here and the same
thing with the north Carolina case that you're
talking about for the independent state legislature
theory, you know, the justices instead of
letting lower courts and lower courts with
a nice mix of Republican and Democratic appointees
or even in one of these cases below, you know,
two trump appointees instead of letting the
lower courts, you know, work it out that way
and leaving that for the current election
cycle. The the current Supreme Court has gotten
more aggressive into stopping uh stopping
the state action, the state lower court action.
So they didn't need to do that. But, you know,
I will say that the court as a whole, in its
method, in its signaling in these cases and
just to step back just for a tiny bit on other,
another racial issue and that would be a affirmative
action on campuses, as you know, Just in that
case, that they're going to hear Monday. They
didn't have to agree to hear the Harvard and
University of North Carolina challenges. That's,
you know, that's not like this voting context.
They didn't have to take up those cases to
say we're going to revisit a 1978 precedent
on race. You know, kind of in the same the
same arena as some of these racial issues
we've been talking about, But they reached
out for those cases and just as they have
signaled to state legislators that they are
sort of open for business in these in these
kinds of challenges. They're doing that in
other areas of race to jess. Yeah. So let's
hold on that voting rights chat. We can circle
back to it at the end because I do have a
few more questions, especially for Bradley
as well. But let's talk about this other big
case that's coming up that will affect will
affect voting elections in general. The Independent
State legislature theory, Ellie I want to
tee you up for this. Break it down for us
in 15 seconds or so or less. You know, what
is this theory and what's at stake at the
Supreme Court when they hear this case on
December seven, I can usually answer quickly.
I'll ask for a little more time than 15 seconds
with leave of your honor, Judge Schneider.
So, the the constitution says that state legislatures
have the right to determine manner and place
of choosing of presidential electors. How
are we gonna hold our elections? How are we
going to award our electoral votes? That has
long been understood to mean state courts
as modified. Excuse me, State legislatures
as modified by state courts. So, if a state
legislature comes up with some method, but
then the state Supreme Court says no, that's
unconstitutional, then it's unconstitutional.
And you have to figure out some other way
the argument that's being advanced now, this
I sl independent State legislatures argument
is state legislatures can do whatever they
want and nobody including stay, courts can
do anything about it, which is as extreme
as it sounds. And to use an example that I've
used before my home state here in New Jersey,
if our state legislature passed a law saying
the way we're gonna decide our electoral votes
is we're gonna all gather at Giants football
Stadium and flip a coin. And heads means they
all go to the democrat and tails means they'll
go to the republican. That would obviously
be unconstitutional. If the Supreme Court
of the State of New Jersey said can't do it,
it's unconstitutional. That would have no
effect under the independent state legislatures
doctrine. So you can see where this is going
and you can see where there's potential mischief
here, because if this theory of the independent
state legislatures is validated, won the states
will be unchecked. And to this was the kind
of thing that donald trump and his supporters
were prevailing upon state legislators in
Wisconsin Arizona uh elsewhere michigan Georgia
to try to do to say, well, you're the State
Legislature, you can just do whatever you
want. So this is a loaded case more versus
harper and in my view, one of the most important
ones on the docket, this this term, Yeah,
a loaded case. Indeed. So Joe. And I want
to ask you, do you really think that the Supreme
Court is going to go all the way here and
say Yes, we believe in this theory. State
legislatures can do whatever they want, can't
really be um can't really be overruled by
state courts that could potentially go to
a federal court of the Supreme Court. Do you
think? I mean, this has been such a hot topic
since the 2020 race. What do you think the
Supreme Court's gonna ultimately say or do
here? Uh jess, I think this is one where they
pulled their punches a little bit. This is
this one is so big and there are so many potential
ramifications for state power, you know, power
within a state, uh the legislature of the
state courts, the governor, there's so many
scenarios that I think would have to play
out for them to come in at this point without
any kind of really uh lower court action on
this on this topic, in a way that's thrashed
it out. I think it would be very risky. And
even though three of the most conservative
justices have signaled that there, you know,
they have an appetite for this. And Brett
Kavanaugh has, has said the at least it's
time to explore it. I don't think they're
ready to really plunge ahead the way they've
been doing on, say, the voting rights act.
And that's because, you know, right now, the
state legislatures are dominated by republicans
and, you know, it seems like so many of the
Supreme Court actions these days benefit republicans.
But, you know, you just don't know, I mean,
you take you take some of these state legislatures
that that they have a potential to go rogue
themselves right now. The court is worried
about state courts going rogue or rejecting
state state legislatures. But you know, it
will cut both ways. And I think they I can
see them allowing uh you know, preventing
the extreme any kind of challenge to the extreme
partisan gerrymandering north Carolina. But
I am not anticipating a really sweeping ruling
because it's still an area that has to be
worked out. The theory as it was first articulated
by William Rehnquist in just a three justice
opinion back during Bush v gore was joined
only by Scalia, antonin Scalia and Clarence,
thomas couldn't even get the support of justices,
Kennedy and O'Connor back then as they even
ruled for George Bush. And I just think it's
it was, it was a theory that went nowhere.
Nobody ceased upon it until the trump until
the trump campaign in 2020. And I, as much
as I think that they could this court could
take a step in that direction. I don't see
it completely ceding power to state uh state
courts, with state legislatures, pardon me?
With no state court possibility of checks
under state constitutions. Right? So Bradley,
give me your take on this. The fact that this
theory has even gained enough traction uh,
to now be before the Supreme Court in the
year 2022. And also the fact of what we're
seeing potentially in less than two weeks
at the midterm elections. You know, we've
already seen lawsuits filed in advance, sort
of disputing voter eligibility. We could see
a flurry of lawsuits after And this is just
for a midterm election and could be multiple
times more what we see in terms of litigation
2020 and it's all based on this idea that
Trump flouted these, these um false election
fraud claims. So what are you bracing for?
What are you concerned about? What do you
see? Well, let me just say, first of all,
I hope john is right, I hope that the court
has sense enough not to take this uh, this
bait. Um, but it is concerning that, that
it's even before the court. Um, it is just
one in a series of um markers that that this
country is moving further and further away
from principles of democracy and that's dangerous.
Uh, and I think, I think there's a very heightened
sensitivity to it. You've seen, you've seen
a lot of people turning out early to express
their opinions at the, at the voting booth.
You know, we mentioned the Dobbs case earlier.
Um, I think that was a wake up call to americans
um, you know that this is this, this is a
threat to um principles of freedom and democracy,
that that all americans hold dear and should
hold dear. I mean, if they can take away,
you know, the right uh you know, for women
to make decisions uh you know that affect
their own bodies and their own health. What
comes next? I mean that injustice is not going
to stop there and uh Clarence thomas, I believe
it was made uh made that made that explicit.
I mean that you know, the right to privacy
is is that issue, the right to marry the right
for same sex couples to to have freedom in
their relationships, all of it is on the table.
And as people come to the ballot box, this
november, uh they are worried about that and
they need to make their decisions um in that
light because you know, we are a couple of
elections away and maybe one election away
um from having the basic um you know, notions
of democracy that secure our freedoms in this
country um you know, those are in danger.
And to that end, Ellie, I got a really interesting
question right off the bat, even before we
started. So obviously a very engaged and excited
participant in this joe from California and
this is what he says, is it constitutionally
possible to have a national referendum on
the right to vote creating national standards
and methods like vote by mail, I assume not
because elections are regulated state to state,
but what do you think of that question? It's
a it's a great question. A smart question.
A creative question, but the answer's no.
Um it is possible to pass legislation theoretically,
but we do have a decentralized election system
here. There is no federal Department of Elections.
Um and I think that's a good thing. I think
that's by design and I think 2020 showed us
why we really have 50 or 51 counting these
separate state level bureaus of election that
administer their own election. I mean, imagine
if as donald trump as we've seen through the
january six hearings was pulling every lever
of power available to him. Imagine if we would
have to be located within the executive branch?
There was a federal department of elections
with a secretary of elections who worked under
the president. I mean, it would have been
one stop shopping for what donald trump was
trying to do by pressuring doj by pressuring
Arizona Wisconsin Georgia by pressuring the
vice president. If you just had one place
administering this all, then your federalizing,
your centralizing and I think you're opening
it up to more potential mischief in danger.
And I know people, I'm sure people are asking
what can be done, can there be um can we,
can we add justices to the court? Can we impeach
the answer is yes and yes, but neither of
those things are gonna happen. Yes. A Supreme
Court justice can be impeached. Federal judges
have been impeached. It's just not going to
happen politically. Yes, you can expand the
number of justices on the Supreme Court. You
uh, you don't even need to amend the constitution
to do that. The constitution does not say
it must be nine. Um, we've actually changed
the number over the years. It's been as low
as five and as high as 10, but the current
number of nine has been in place through a
federal statute for over 100 50 years now.
So you would need your Congress, your Houses
of Congress to pass it and the president to
sign it. And joe biden gotten a little bit
of trouble during his 2020 campaign because
he had been for decades against expanding
the number of just this is on the court. He
took blowback. He tried to mitigate his position,
ended up appointing a commission which issued
a report with a bunch of mishmash about here
are some options. And of course nothing got
done. So sorry to be the bearer of bad news
to those hoping for sweeping reform. But one
of the things with the Supreme Court is, there's
not a heck of a lot that can be done outside
of the nomination and confirmation of justices
themselves. So that's why it's important to
vote to elect people who you want to see eventually
appoint maybe more justices. You know, we're
coming up actually, we're at 2 46 but I think
we might have time for. I think two more questions
that I'd like to throw. First of all, Bradley.
I got um, I got a good kind of, overall overarching
question from philo in California. And this
speaks outside the courts. Maybe if people
are frustrated what they've seen courts, the
Supreme Court doing, the broader question
is, you know, what do you consider the most
effective way to strengthen voting rights
at this pivotal point is that people lobbying
their own individual lawmakers in states,
going to the ballot boxes, What is it for
you? Well, I think that's a good segue. I
actually wanted to hop back on the point that
Ellie was just, uh, talking about in your
last question about, um, you know, what can
be done at the federal level? Um, and I do
think that while we do have a central decentralized
form of elections, the constitution does allow
Congress to regulate federal elections and
the regulation of federal elections can have
a, you know, a palliative effect on, on elections,
both federal and state generally, because
there there's there's only one voter registration
system etcetera. So, one of the things that,
that we can do on the federal level is to
pass legislation like the john LewiS voting
rights Act that would restore um, the preclearance
provision modernize and restore the preclearance
provision and that would go a long way into,
into helping to prevent um, discriminatory
laws from taking effect in the first place.
Uh, that's, that's a solid thing that we can
do. You've seen some discussions in Congress
around the Electoral count Act, the ancient
law that would have, you know, that will that
if reformed will prevent something like another
january. So six style um, of a stolen election.
Right? Where they where you you just redefine
what the role of Congress is in counting those
electoral college votes. Right? So there are
things that you do on a legislative level.
Well, we'll have to wait and see on that.
I wanna end this maybe with a question for
joan and this comes to us from joy in Ohio.
But the reason why I'm going to ask it and
last is because I think it sort of encapsulates
the sentiment that maybe some americans have,
especially after the overturning of roe v
wade and also looks toward what's at stake
with the voting rights cases here. It says,
how does the supra the court hoped to remain
legitimate if they continue to take away freedom
and liberties that are considered american
norms? Again, a very overarching question,
but it does touch it. A sentiment that I think
many americans are probably feeling at this
point. What's your thought on this question?
Yeah. And I think it's a question that actually
the justices asked themselves Jessica is that,
uh, and I think the only answer is that they
have to be judged over time. And we're all
still sort of getting accustomed to what they
did this summer in many rulings and we're
gonna have to see how they now respond to
the public reaction as a rule in these upcoming
cases. And if this is really the new normal,
which it might be given the justices, I'll
remind everybody that 44 of the justices are
quite young. Three of the three trump appointees
are only in their fifties. So this is a court
that Joy will have uh Joy who asked the question
that she will have for probably her lifetime
and maybe her Children's lifetime just because
they'll they'll be with us and they will either
have they will either continue on the path
they're on and this will be the court miracle
will have or they will pivot in some way that
maybe does restore more public confidence.
Excellent. Well, thank you everyone joe piscopo
rick Bradley heard Elie Honig for joining
us and I want to make a note for everyone
who has joined us online. Thank you so much
for jumping into the conversation and hearing
what our experts have to say. I mean, you
can get a lot more of the election resources
and I'm gonna give you the website right now
CNN dot com backslash election backslash 2022.
Obviously our team here in CNN is closely
following the midterm elections where we've
already got teams on the ground. We're also
looking at the legal implications. So, a lot
to come here, you can also register for more
citizens conversations that's at CNN dot com
backslash citizen. And I want to note if you
were really intrigued by the talk of the Supreme
Court, the Supreme Court is still live streaming
all of its arguments. As john mentioned on
monday, they'll be back at it with two cases
dealing with affirmative action, the fact
that they may actually ban potentially affirmative
action and the consideration of race in admissions
decisions at universities. So, you know, you
can log on, get our take, but also go straight
to the source at the Supreme Court. So thank
you everyone, joan and Bradley and Ellie as
well. We really appreciate guys joining us
for this citizen by CNN talk and we'll see
you soon. Bye.